do you think there is a nuclear threat
do you think about this do you worry
about this that there is a threat of a
tactical nuclear weapon being dropped I
think that possibility exists either way
and I think the responsibility for that
is on Russia because it can't it just
can't be the case that if you have nukes
you're allowed to invade countries and
take their land because of anything I
think that that down the road also
increased increases the potential for
nuclear problems in the future right
because at that point either every
single country has to acquire their own
nuclear weapons because if you don't
Russia is going to mess with you or
every single country has to join NATO
and now what we're back at square zero
Ground Zero square one where people like
oh well look all these countries joining
NATO is aggressive towards Russia like
what are you gonna do
yeah you've mentioned that um there's a
complicated calculus going on with the
countries that have uh they have nuclear
weapons and what's our responsibility
are you allowed to do anything you want
to countries that don't have nuclear
weapons
that's a really tricky discussion for
sure because what is UI supposed to do
if Russia drops a tactical nuclear
weapon there's a set of options
none of which are good and
it's such a tricky moment right now
because uh the things that Biden and
other public figures say I feel like has
a significant impact on the way this
game turns out because I think mutually
sure destruction is partially a game of
words now I mean I believe in the power
of our conversation
of leaders talking to each other I feel
like
you have to have a balance between
threat and compromise
and like
empathy for the needs the geopolitical
the economic needs of a Nation but also
sort of respect
and represent your own interests so it's
a tricky one like how do you play the
how do you play the hand it reminds me
of um I don't know if you've ever heard
in like evolutionary psych or Evolution
or biology there are things called Tit
for Tat strategies it kind of reminds me
of that where it's like if like uh there
are a whole bunch of these little
biological mechanisms where creatures
will develop like socializing like Tit
for Tat if you do something bad to me
I'm gonna do something bad for you and
then more complicated schemes will come
out where it'll be like tit tip for Tat
where it's like you can make one mistake
and then I'm gonna get you if you do a
second one or could be Tit for Tat or
they're gonna be tit for a tat tat for
there's like all these like back and
forths where creatures kind of optimize
themselves and
um yeah I think something the United
States did really well in terms of that
kind of conversational strategy and I
approved of this in the beginning was
Biden was very clear about setting out
like the exact level of U.S involvement
for the war we're not going to do a
no-fly zone there's not going to be US
troops on the ground in Ukraine but we
are going to send a whole bunch of money
and a whole bunch of arms and a whole
bunch of Intel to them and I thought he
did a good job at laying out like the
limitation of the OS involvement while
opening as much as we could in the ways
we could help but the um yeah that
looming threat of some sort of tactical
nuclear weapon I think on the table
right now is like it's going to be the
annihilation of like Russian sea forces
and everything but you know what happens
if it continues to escalate that's like
a world that nobody wants to nobody
wants to be in